انظر إسرائيل ليست روسيا غزة ليست
أوكرانيا إنه وضع مختلف ولكن
قطع الإمدادات قطع الحرارة
قطع المياه عن
المدنيين ما
الفرق حسنًا أولاً أشكرك على
قولك أن إسرائيل ليست روسيا لأن
إسرائيل ليست روسيا ثانيًا المدنيون
هم مدنيون على اتصال  نعم، نعم بالتأكيد،
إنهم كذلك ويستحقون كما
قلت أمام لجنة التنسيق الإدارية الحصول على الماء
والدواء والغذاء، ونحن نعمل
بنشاط لضمان حدوث ذلك،
ويمكنني أن أخبركم هذا الصباح جيك أنني
كنت على اتصال مع
نظرائي الإسرائيليين في غضون ذلك  الساعة الأخيرة
أه من أبلغني أنهم قاموا
بالفعل بإعادة تشغيل أنبوب المياه في
جنوب غزة والذي كان موضوع
نقاش على مدار
الأيام القليلة الماضية ستواصل الولايات المتحدة
العمل مع إسرائيل مع
الأمم المتحدة  مع مصر والأردن ومع الكثير
من المجموعات على الأرض للتأكد من حصول
الفلسطينيين الأبرياء
على تلك الضروريات الأساسية وحمايتهم
من القصف لأنهم
يستحقون هذا الحق، والحق في تلك
الضروريات، والحق في السلامة
والأمن كل يوم.  بقدر ما يفعله
المدنيون الأوكرانيون أو المدنيون في أي مكان،
والولايات المتحدة لم تصرح بأي شيء
بشأن ذلك، فنحن نعمل بجد على أننا
نعمل للتأكد من أن
هذا هو الحال بينما يتكشف هذا الأمر
وهو شيء حدث  لقد كانت
أولوية قصوى بالنسبة للرئيس بايدن بالنسبة
للوزير بلينكين ولي، لكنك
لا تقول للإسرائيليين أن يسمحوا
للمستشفيات الفلسطينية بالحصول على
الطاقة، وموقفنا هو أن أه
المستشفيات يجب أن تكون قادرة على العمل،
ويجب ألا يتم استهداف الأشخاص، ويجب أن
يتمكن الناس من الحصول عليها  الوصول إلى
الرعاية الطبية المنقذة للحياة، نحن لا نحلل هذه
التصريحات، ولا نقول أن هناك
نوعًا من التحذير لها، فهذه بيانات
تصريحية بسيطة وواضحة، إن
موقفنا يتوافق مع
قانون النزاعات المسلحة AR وقانون
الحرب  إنه يتوافق مع وجهة نظرنا كما
قدمناها وأود فقط أن أقول
لجيك أن هناك الكثير من التقارير في
ضباب الحرب حول الأشياء التي تحدث،
ولن نرد على كل
منها لأننا سنسعى للوضوح
في  بالطريقة المناسبة ولكننا
لن نتراجع أبدًا عن مبادئنا الأساسية
واقتراحنا الأساسي الذي قدمناه
علنًا وسرًا بشأن
وجهة نظرنا حول كيفية
حماية المدنيين. لم أطرح عليك أيًا من
قصص الحرب التي قرأتها  رأيت قصصًا
تلوم إسرائيل على أشياء اتضح فيما بعد أن
حماس هي التي فعلتها، أفهم ذلك،
لكن لدينا
تقارير وأنا متأكد من أن لديك تقارير أيضًا تفيد
بأن مئات الأفراد العالقين
في غزة هم مواطنون أمريكيون، وأنت تعلم
ذلك أيضًا هناك  هناك أيضًا مئات أه
الآلاف من الأمريكيين في إسرائيل الذين
يحاولون الخروج أيضًا
وإدارة بايدن تبذل الكثير لإخراج
هؤلاء الأفراد. 29 من
الأفراد الذين قتلتهم حماس كانوا
أمريكيين وأعتقد أن
الأمر كذلك  شيء مثل 40
أمريكيًا مجهولي المصير ربما
تم أسرهم من قبل حماس ولكن
أريد أن أتحدث إليكم عن
امرأة أمريكية فلسطينية تحدثنا إليها
تدعى حنين أوكال، وهي من نيوجيرسي
ولديها ثلاثة أطفال تبلغ من العمر 82 عامًا وشهرين، لقد
أرسلت إليك  المقابلة التي أجريناها معها
في وقت سابق من الأسبوع وصلت إلى
الحدود معبر رفح ولا تستطيع
الخروج ولا تستطيع الخروج من غزة لأن
المصريين لن يفتحوا المعبر
استمع إلى ما قالته لي في وقت سابق من هذا
الأسبوع  لقد حاولنا الاتصال بقناة MBC الأمريكية عدة
مرات ولسوء الحظ
لم يتمكنوا من مساعدتنا على الإطلاق، لقد اتصلت بهم
عبر الهاتف عبر البريد الإلكتروني وأرسلت رسالة نصية
واتصلت بأرقام مختلفة ولكن لا أحد
لم أتمكن من سماع رد من أي شخص، نحن جميعًا
هنا نشعر  تخلى عن ذلك ونحن
نشعر أننا تركنا
وشأننا، ولا أعرف كم مليارات
الدولارات التي نمنحها للمصريين كل عام،
أخبرنا لماذا لا يمكنك أن تطلب من رئيس CCE أن
يفتح الحدود للسماح للأمريكيين بالخروج، لقد
أخبرنا الرئيس  إن قيام CCE بفتح
الحدود للسماح للأمريكيين بالخروج، فإن
الوضع هناك عند المعبر هو
في الواقع أكثر تعقيدًا، وقد وافق المصريون في الواقع على السماح للأمريكيين
بالمغادرة للحصول على ممر آمن عبر
معبر رفح، ووافق الإسرائيليون على
ضمان أن المنطقة المحيطة هناك
ستكون  آمنون على الأقل بقدر ما كانوا
قادرين على القيام بذلك، وكان السؤال عندما حاولنا
تحريك مجموعة بالأمس هو في الواقع أن
حماس تتخذ خطوات لمحاولة منع
حدوث ذلك ولكننا
نواصل العمل على مدار الساعة
ونحن نفعل ذلك  كل ما في وسعنا
للتأكد من أن المواطنين الأمريكيين الموجودين في
غزة يمكنهم المرور عبر
وزير المعبر الحدودي بلينكين هو في الواقع موجود في
مصر اليوم للقاء الرئيس المصري،
وهذا على رأس قائمته
للمساعدة في إخراج هؤلاء المواطنين الأمريكيين
من غزة.  غزة أه أي شخص أه مواطن أمريكي
يجب أن يكون له الحق في المرور الحر
من هناك ومن ثم تجعل
الحكومة الأمريكية تسهل سفرهم إلى الوطن
نعم لا أشك في أن
المشكلة الأكبر في كل هذا هو كاماس
جيك سوفين شكرا  أنت تقدر ذلك كثيرًا